PROFESSOR: So now I have this.
And what I need to do is
I need to transform.
So I need to take E.coli
growing in a test tube.
And I need to put into it a
whole collection of zillions
and zillions of plasmid
molecules, plasmid circles
that all have different
pieces of human DNA.
One of these things might
have ARG1, one ARG2,
one ARG3, et cetera.
Or if it's human DNA, one of
them your hemoglobin, one of
them your collagen, whatever.
I have to throw the DNA on
top of the bacteria.
And then I need to come up with
some engineering trick to
make the bacteria take up this
DNA across their cell
membranes and use it.
Why should I be able to
persuade bacteria
to take up my DNA?
AUDIENCE: They do it anyway.
PROFESSOR: They do it anyway.
Remember, we said they
like to exchange DNA.
That's kind of their
thing, right?
They pick up DNA from their
environment anyway.
See, as usual, we haven't really
invented something.
What we've done is we have
used the natural property
that's out there.
The natural properties, bacteria
like to slurp up DNA.
Now in fairness, some pretty
cool protocols were developed
that improve the ability
to do it.
You treat the DNA,
a little nastily.
You give it certain ions.
You heat shock it in
a certain way.
And then it encourages it
to slurp up DNA better.
But the ability to slurp
up DNA was there
in the first place.
We couldn't have given it the
ability to slurp up DNA if it
wasn't there.
But we can always goose it up,
improve it in certain ways.
And there are great protocols
that were developed in order
to be able to increase the
efficiency of such
transformation.
So now we now have our E.coli.
Here's an E.coli.
Some of the E.coli have acquired
a plasmid containing
human DNA or maybe, if we
used yeast, yeast DNA.
Some of them have it, right?
Because it's kind of
a random process.
Some slurp it up,
some haven't.
So I might have, I don't know,
maybe one in 100 of my cells
will have slurped up DNA.
But 99 in 100 won't have
slurped up DNA.
I want to plate these out on a
Petri plate and grow them up
into individual colonies.
But I would like it to be the
case, please, that the
individual colonies that grow up
are only the ones that got
my plasmid.
I really don't want to see
all these guys who
didn't get my plasmid.
So what do I do?
Do I go in there with a
microscope and try to figure
out which ones got my
human DNA plasmid?
So I would love to plate it out
and only have the guys who
got my plasmid grow.
How do I arrange that only
the guys who got my
plasmid will grow?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: For something.
I got to put in a gene into that
plasmid so that only the
guys who get that will grow.
Any ideas for what gene
might go in there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: How about a gene
conferring resistance to an
antibiotic.
And then what could I do?
Well, I could plate.
I'm going to select--
see this E.coli here,
it had my plasmid.
And it's going to have a
drug resistance gene.
And it will grow up.
This guy over here, he didn't
get a drug resistance gene.
He doesn't grow up.
The only ones who grow up
have a drug resistant--
wait a second.
Why doesn't this guy grow up?
AUDIENCE: You add the drug.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I got to add
the drug, good point.
So what I'm going to do is I
add my drug to the plate.
I add my drug to the medium,
to the Petri plate here.
And now my Petri plate is say
a penicillin plate or a
streptomycin plate or a
ampicillin plate or a
kanamycin plate or whatever.
And then the only things that
could grow up are the ones
that have resistance to whatever
antibiotic I used.
So I grow them up
on that plate.
And they grew up just fine.
The ones who didn't get-- now
how did I get that antibiotic
gene into the plasmid?
It actually comes that way
in nature, sort of.
Now when I get good,
I can move them
around from one to another.
But nature thought
of it first.
Nature gave us something that
had an origin of replication
and an antibiotic
resistance gene.
And we could just add
things to it.
It had everything we needed.
It had the ability
to slurp up DNA.
It had the ability to confer a
new property on the cells like
resistance to antibiotics.
And when we're done, we
have a library here.
And we call this a library of
cells or colonies, each one of
which has a distinct piece of
human DNA, each one of which
has a different piece
of human DNA.
Let me stop and ask,
any questions?
This is like one of the coolest
new procedures invented.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible that
the same E.coli takes in two
of the things?
PROFESSOR: Is it possible that
same E.coli takes in two?
Yes, turns out we do this at a
dilution in a way so that most
take up zero, some take up one,
and a couple take up two.
And what we say there
is, oh well.
It's not so common.
And we live with it.
What else?
AUDIENCE: You need to make sure
the bacteria that doesn't
already have a resistance
to it?
PROFESSOR: I better use a
bacteria that's not already
resistant to this antibiotic,
good point.
That's right.
And I can do that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When making those
vectors, how do you make sure
it only cuts once so you can put
one piece of human DNA and
it doesn't break apart?
PROFESSOR: Oh, so what if the
vector had five EcoR1 sites?
People have engineered them
to just have one.
In fact, what they've really
done now is they engineer them
so that within the vector
there's a little region,
called a polylinker, that has
many different sites for many
different restriction enzymes,
depending on which one you
might want to use.
And they're all right over
here in the same place.
And they go around and
they fix the vector.
So it doesn't have any
of the others.
You could, for example cut it
open and change the sequence a
little bit.
All these tools are
available to us.
And rather than you
having to do it,
they're all in the catalog.
The catalog has vectors that
have polylinkers, don't have
any other cut sites, et cetera.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you isolate the
sequence you want if the
cutting sequence
is so frequent?
PROFESSOR: Oh, so you're
asking two questions.
One is you're asking how do I
find the particular thing I'm
looking for on the plate
amongst the millions of
colonies that might grow up?
Or are you asking if the
cutting sequence is so
frequent, how do I avoid cutting
in the middle of the
sequence I want?
AUDIENCE: Well both, I guess.
If you want to replicate human
genes, if you have a bunch of
DNA, how can you make
it so that you
isolate only that gene?
PROFESSOR: OK, so now there
are really two questions
you're asking.
They're both really
good questions.
One, I take my human DNA.
And let's say we're trying
to clone the gene for
beta-globin.
Beta-globin is a part
of hemoglobin.
It's one of the two proteins
in hemoglobin.
And let's say the beta-globin
gene is a certain length.
And suppose the beta-globin
gene actually has several
EcoR1 sites.
I'm going to chop it up
into multiple pieces.
That's bad, right?
That's step one bad.
How do I avoid that?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Paste it.
PROFESSOR: Paste it again.
Oh no, once I cut it, all the
pieces of human DNA are
floating around.
How do I know what
to paste to what?
AUDIENCE: Methylate it.
PROFESSOR: Methylate it.
So first I could take
my human DNA.
And I could methylate it.
Then it won't get cut
up by the enzyme.
But what's the problem
with that?
None of it will get cut
up with the enzyme.
Suppose I did something that
was a compromise though.
Suppose I added a little
methylase and a little
restriction enzyme.
And the methylase went around
randomly and put some
methyl groups on.
Then these wouldn't get cut.
And sometimes it might
put on that.
And those wouldn't get cut.
And it would just
get cut here.
I would call such a thing
a partial digestion.
It can be done one
of two ways.
I could just add a little bit of
restriction enzyme and not
give it too long.
Or I could add a mixture of a
little restriction enzyme, a
little methylation enzyme,
and let them have at it.
And if I had the right balance,
I could cut on
average every second restriction
site or on average
every fourth restriction site.
Or if I use a different ratio,
every tenth restriction site.
So I actually can play a
stochastic, a probabilistic
game of cutting every second,
fourth, tenth site and
obviously get a mix.
I'll get a mixture of
different cuts.
But in terms of cutting in the
middle of my gene, I no longer
care because I can do
partial digestions.
Now that means that in my
library I might not just have
the Eco fragments.
But because I did a partial
digestion, I might have two
consecutive or five consecutive
Eco fragments, if
I've done a partial digestion.
But your question
still stands.
How do I find my right gene?
How do I figure out which
is the right gene?
So I've got this.
I've got my plate.
I've done this amazing
purification.
Every one of these guys has a
chunk of human DNA that might
be just one EcoR1 fragment.
Or if I happen to have done a
partial digestion, it might be
two EcoR1 fragments.
But it turns out that this
guy here is beta-globin.
How do I know?
I've purified beta-globin.
I get points, right?
I purified beta-globin.
Somewhere on my plate is a pure
beta-globin sitting there.
But the problem is I don't
know where it is.
How am I going to find it?
They all still look the same.
They look like bacteria.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: To do what?
AUDIENCE: Well, in this case
find some way to determine
whether or not a certain certain
has beta-globin.
PROFESSOR: Whether a
certain colony--
AUDIENCE: Has beta-globin.
PROFESSOR: Has the beta-globin
gene in it.
So I somehow have to test each
colony to figure out whether
it's got the beta-globin
gene in it.
How do you propose to do that?
AUDIENCE: There's some
observation you can make.
PROFESSOR: Talk loud.
AUDIENCE: There's some
observation you can make.
PROFESSOR: And you make
that observation.
Right, so--
I'm with you.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You basically
want some ribosomes
to create the proteins.
PROFESSOR: Oh, oh, oh, so maybe
I can make that thing
make beta-globin.
Oh, and then look
for the protein.
Problem with that is E.coli
doesn't read human
instructions.
So E.coli's polymerase
won't read.
But it's a great idea.
Maybe we can do that.
Any other ideas?
How are we going to
find our gene?
We've made a library.
We have a library.
It's a bigger library
than MIT.
It's got more volumes
How are we're going
to find our book?
AUDIENCE: Put it in a medium
without beta-globin.
PROFESSOR: Put a medium
AUDIENCE: See if it
grows or not.
PROFESSOR: See if it grows up.
E.coli couldn't care less
about beta-globin.
It doesn't need beta-globin.
And in addition, it won't
produce beta-globin because it
doesn't read the human
instructions.
All right, so we've gone
to all this trouble.
We've made a library with all
the possible books in the
human genome.
And we don't know how
to use the library.
Friday's lecture let us discuss
how to use the library.